first woman astronaut discusses her book
exploring our solar system it's an hour
okay I think we'll go ahead and get
started good afternoon my name is
Katherine Ivey and on behalf of
imaginary lines in the Sally Ride
science club I want to welcome you to
the Sally Ride Science Festival at UCLA
and thank you for coming out today and
this afternoon it's my pleasure to
introduce Sally Ride who in addition to
being a physicist and an astronaut is
also an author and she's going to talk
today about her new book exploring our
solar system this is her fourth book for
children and she has co-written this
with Tam O'Shaughnessy it's published by
Random House and is going to be
published on November 11th we were able
to get some copies here today so that
Sally could sign some and Sally's going
to describe the book and then she's
going to answer any questions you all
might have so without any further ado
here's Sally thank you and I'm pleased
that you could all come over to hear a
little bit about the book I'm pretty
excited about about the way that the
book turned out and I think that just
from what I've heard of some of the some
of the kids who've had a chance to flip
through it it appears that they they
like it too interestingly enough
whenever I go talk to a group of kids
let's say kids 6 7 8 years old one of
the common questions that I get is which
planets have you visited
well of course nobody has been to any
planets besides earth no humans have set
foot on any of the other planets in our
in our solar system but back in 1969 and
1970 12 people were lucky enough to get
get a chance to set foot on on the moon
the moon is not a planet the moons a
moon and just to drive the point home as
to why people haven't visited other
planets yet the moons really close it
took the Apollo astronauts only a couple
of days to get to the moon if we were
going to send people to Mars it would
take them eight months or nine months or
so to get to Mars and that gives you an
idea of the scale of an expedition that
that would be but over the last four
decades or so we've been sending our
eyes and our ears out into the solar
system to explore for us in the form of
increasingly sophisticated spacecraft
and those spacecraft have completely
revolutionized what we know about the
solar system our understanding has
completely changed of the planets and
their moons and of how the solar system
formed and also it's taught us how
little we really know about it in fact
it's probably caused us to ask more
questions than it's been it's actually
answered so what I wanted to do this
afternoon fairly briefly is this kind of
give you a quick tour of the solar
system starting with when and how its
formed and I'm along a copy of the books
that I'm going to read a few parts of
the book as I as I go along just to kind
of give you a sense of what it what it
contains and how we've how we've chosen
to describe various things various
things in it you know when I was
orbiting space in the in the space
shuttle and had a chance to look down at
the surface of Earth I could look down
and see the blue oceans I could see the
orange desert
so I could see the snow-capped mountains
I could see evidence of life on the
planet I could see vegetation in the
Amazon you know the Amazon rainforest or
the Nile the Nile River Delta and in
fact it's surprisingly enough it was it
was very easy to see evidence of
civilization from from that altitude as
well and that goes everywhere from long
runways like the runway that the Space
Shuttle lands on or launch complex where
the shuttle is launched from two other
long runways around the country bridges
over rivers and even city lights at
night and I brought along a slide of
what the earth looks like at night just
to give you a give you a little bit of a
sense of sense of that but let me just
read a read a section from the book here
earth would have looked very different
to an astronaut four billion years ago
blue water filled different oceans
thunder clouds hid nameless continents
and the barren land shows no sign of
life there was no life anywhere four
billion years ago on our planet further
back in time five billion years ago a
starship passing through our region of
space would not have slowed down for a
second look there was nothing to see no
earth no Sun no solar system nothing but
a huge tenuous cloud of gas that cloud
eventually contracted to form our Sun
and all of its planets everything we
know came from that cloud and that's
really kind of an amazing thing to think
of when you when you stop to think about
it in fact our solar system started as a
big cold cloud light-years across of
mostly hydrogen and helium gas with a
little bit of other gases and some kind
of grains grains of dust and everything
came from it it started to collapse
under its own gravity and broke up into
hundreds of smaller clouds and each of
those clouds continued to to collapse
this group of clouds is kind of called a
stellar nursery by astronomers who study
this thing and our cloud was one of the
clouds in this stellar nursery it kept
collapsing and collapsing and collapsing
as it did the the center of the cloud
collapse to get hotter and hotter and
hotter and hotter and denser and denser
and denser the center of the cloud
eventually became the Sun and it when it
became hot enough and dense enough for
the hydrogen atoms to collide against
each other with such force that they
collided and formed helium creating
nuclear fusion that's when the Sun began
to shine it kind of turned on and became
the Sun at that time this really early
early Sun at the same time that that was
that the Sun was forming the rest of the
cloud kind of the outer part was was
flattening down into a disk and that
disk swirled around the Sun and
eventually out of that disk came the
planets and the way that that happened
is really you know anybody that's rolled
a snow ball down a hill has a little bit
of an idea of what happened although
that the cloud was mostly hydrogen and
helium gas there were little little
particles of heavier elements in the in
the gas and what those particles were
made of depended on how far from the Sun
you were because near the Sun it was
really hot so you couldn't have ice
particles all you could have a kind of
rock particles and in that area near the
Sun those little rock particles kind of
slowly collided with each other they
collided they coalesced they collided
with more particles going around they
class they grew bigger and bigger and
bigger in this kind of snowball fashion
so first they were kind of the size of
your fist and then they were inside of
size of this room then they were the
size of UCLA campus and eventually they
just got bigger and bigger and bigger to
form what we called planetesimals that
are big rocks about the size of small
moons and those moons in a series of
colossal collisions combined to form the
four inner planets the so called
terrestrial planets Mercury Venus Earth
and and Mars now just a little further
out beyond Mars it was cool enough out
in the disk it was far enough from the
solar system that ice particles could
form so instead of just rock going
around and kind of coalescing you had
rock and ice going around coalescing
there's a little bit more of it so there
was more stuff out there that could kind
of combine and that combination process
happened further out and that produced
the next four planets out the four giant
planets Jupiter Saturn Uranus and and
Neptune and there are several reasons
why they got a lot bigger but suffice it
to say for for our purposes here they
did get a lot bigger than that the
terrestrial planets this coalescing
continued even out beyond Neptune out
there it was colder a little bit more
ice than than rock but but thousands and
thousands and thousands of these icy
planetesimals formed out beyond Neptune
but the the planet building process
didn't really come to completion so we
don't have any big planets out beyond
Neptune but one of those icy
planetesimals is Pluto and it happens to
be the largest of this group of group of
objects that we've that we've discovered
out there the the nine planets formed at
the same time four and a half to five
billion years ago out of the same stuff
and they formed really pretty quickly on
you know kind of geologic timescales are
not even geologic you know the scale of
the universe they formed in about a
hundred million years so we went from
having nothing but a cloud to a solar
system with an early Sun and planets in
the space of only a few hundred hundred
million years those planets though even
though they formed from the same the
same stuff are really really different
different worlds and let me show you see
we've got here this slide if you can see
it shows kind of very schematically the
planet building process so up in the
upper left is a cloud and as time goes
on move first over towards the right you
see the clouds starting to condense at
the center the Sun has just kind of
ignited in that one go further down the
planets are starting to kind of sweep
out the stuff that's in their way it's a
more pronounced
further down and by the time you get
down here to the to the bottom instead
of having a disc of gas rolling around
you've actually got planets going around
going around the Sun now I wanted to
spend just a little bit of time on on
each of the planets or at least most of
the planets we probably probably skip a
couple because we got too many of them
the the terrestrial planets from left to
right here are Mercury Venus Earth with
its moon kind of in the corner there and
Mars the forks rest real planets are the
the four closest to the Sun they're all
small they're very similar they're small
they're rocky
they've all got solid surfaces so you
can kind of think of them as a family of
planets now Mercury let me just read you
the overview that we've got in the book
about mercury mercury the closest planet
to the Sun is the smallest of the
terrestrial worlds it's only slightly
larger than our moon this tiny planet is
an inhospitable place it has no
atmosphere its ancient surface is
covered with impact craters and it's
temperature ranges from a scorching 800
degrees Fahrenheit to a frigid 300
degrees below zero Fahrenheit mercury is
the terrestrial planet that we know
least about and why do we know least
about it one reason is that only one
spacecraft Mariner Ken has ever been
there ever since the beginning of the
Space Age and that was a long time ago
was back in 1974 and 75 it actually flew
past mercury three times and took
pictures on its way past mercury so we
haven't even photographed the whole
planet Mercury we've sent no spacecraft
back there since then there are none on
their way now although there are there
are missions that people are talking
about but that's one of the reasons that
we really don't know very much about
mercury the next planet outward from the
Sun is Venus and again let me just read
you our overview about Venus Venus has
often been called Earth's sister planet
it's our nearest planetary neighbor and
almost the same size and composition as
Earth when the two planets first
formed they were nearly identical now
they are about as different as can be
earth is a living planet it has a
moderate climate cool ocean breezes and
plants and animals everywhere venus is
an inferno it's suffocating carbon
dioxide atmosphere creates a greenhouse
effect that makes it the hottest planet
in the solar system hotter even than
mercury by the way its water has long
since boiled away there's nothing alive
on Venus the remarkable thing about
Venus is its carbon dioxide atmosphere
it's so thick because this enormous lis
thick atmosphere it's so thick that the
pressure that you would feel if you were
standing on the surface of Venus that is
kind of the weight of the atmosphere
above you would be about 90 times what
we feel here on earth in this room and
that's enough to crush us it had crush
us it encrusts crushed the buildings it
basically is a very very very high
pressure it's that thick co2 atmosphere
of course that's responsible for the
greenhouse effect
so the greenhouse effect just really
briefly as many of you many of you know
is that the some the sun's light comes
as it hits the top of a planet's
atmosphere it comes straight through its
visible light light that our eyes can
see it's not really stopped by anything
in the atmosphere some is reflected out
by clouds but that's it is and just
makes it right right through and it
warms the planet it warms the earth
doesn't matter whether you're talking
about Venus or earth or Mars once it
hits the surface it starts warming the
planet well that warm planet reradiates
the heat back off into space but it
reread Yeats it in the infrared part of
the spectrum not the visible part of the
spectrum if that infrared radiation
could make it out through the atmosphere
as easily as the visible light came in
there'd be no greenhouse effect but it
turns out that there are several
molecules the most important among them
to us water vapor and carbon dioxide
that absorb infrared really efficiently
and as a result when those atma when
those gases are present in the
atmosphere they can absorb that infrared
that's trying to get out
and prep it and keep the heat in so
Venus has this enormous Li thick
atmosphere anyway and worse worse than
that it's all carbon dioxide so it's a
it is a suffocating greenhouse effect
that makes the surface almost 800
degrees hotter than it would be
otherwise not quite that much but the
reason that Venus is so hot people
expected it to be hotter the nervous
because it's closer to the Sun but they
expected it to be
you know 120 in the shade that sort of
thing
Venus is 850 degrees Fahrenheit all over
the surface of the planet day or night
and it's because of the greenhouse
effect this is what the surface of Venus
looks like to radar that was in in orbit
around the planet for several years and
did a real good job of mapping the
topography of the planet Venus is really
a pretty bad place all the water has
boiled away because it's so hot and it's
a very active planet so active means
volcanoes all over its surface volcanoes
are erupting erupting today and what you
can see in this picture is a a couple of
volcanoes popping up and actually love a
rivers flowing down from from the the
volcanoes so on Venus there are rivers
rivers of lava as long as the
Mississippi River on on earth
well earth is the next planet of course
and you know it's on a day like today or
in fact just sort of any normal day it's
really hard to remember that we live on
a planet you know we're used to just
walking around and seeing trees and
bushes and people and walking in and out
of buildings but in fact we live on a on
a rock that's flying around the Sun
that's rotating on its axis well it's
flying around the Sun and that's
something that that you don't see
standing on the surface of Earth but
earth is also similar to the terrestrial
planets in many ways
it's very different for two important
really important reasons and the two
reasons are related earth is the only
planet that's got liquid water on the
surface and as a result of having liquid
water it's the only planet that we know
of it has life on the on the surface
more about Mars in in a second but so
far we found no liquid water or life on
any other any other planet four billion
years ago let me see what I've got here
this is a actually a picture taken from
the astronauts on the Space Shuttle just
you know we all know there's water on
the planet but you really see it when
you're going around Earth in the shuttle
you know 75% of the surface that you see
is ocean you can see the tail of the
Space Shuttle kind of sticking down from
the the top of the picture here for a
billion years ago at at the beginning of
its existence earth was a really
different place than it is today
it was a hot roiling planet
it had meteors crashing into it all the
time some of these leftover
planetesimals were still flying around
hitting it had a very violent atmosphere
torrential rains that were filling the
ocean basins it was really a bad place
but believe it or not even during those
very early early days under those
horrible conditions the ingredients of
life were there and life began to form
in fact the the evidence that that we've
got is that there was very primitive
microscopic life on Earth three and a
half to 3.8 billion billion years ago
which is right at this really horrible
period in Earth's history all you need
for life to start is water you need
organic molecules and you need some sort
of energy source and all of those were
available on early Earth so just add a
little time and it doesn't need to be
too much time just longer than human
life time longer than our time scale but
given time
life has every possibility of emerging
and one of the things that has been a
real lesson for scientists for the last
couple of decades maybe the last decade
or so that's really changed the way we
think about living things is that life
is really really Hardy and it's very
very adaptable so it can not only start
but thrive under conditions that to us
are just unimaginably harsh and that's
changed the way we look at the prospect
for life on on other other planets life
of course is everywhere on our planet
and if you if you doubted it for a
second you know just take a look at what
the earth looks like at night here we've
got the cities you know basically the
continents outlined in light this is a
composite of thousands and thousands of
photos so this is the famous you know
earth on a cloudless night but you can
see where where civilization is on our
planet just a quick word about about the
moon the only body in the solar system
that people have set foot on other than
other than earth earth didn't always
have a moon when when Earth was was just
forming it formed as a planet without a
moon and the first you know many many
many many times it went around the Sun
it went around the Sun without a moon
but in this horrible early period of the
solar system earth was one day hit by
something about the size of Mars that
just blasted a whole bunch of material
off earth and into orbit around Earth
and that material later coalesced to
form to form the moon this is a picture
that just shows evidence that that
people have been to the moon this is a
picture taken by the Apollo 14
astronauts and what you're seeing are
the the tracks of the lunar rover and
you can see the lunar rover way off in
the distance the distance here I think
this was probably back in 1970 that this
photo was
bacon but those tracks are still in the
lunar soil today the moon doesn't have
an atmosphere there's no wind no water
to erode them so all those tracks and
Neil Armstrong's footprints are still
still on the lunar the lunar surface
this is a really cool picture it looks
it looks fake just take a look at Earth
this is a picture taken by a spacecraft
that was that orbited the moon for quite
a while and you can see the moon in the
foreground and the earth up in the up at
the top of the picture looks completely
fake
moving on to Mars Mars is the the last
of the terrestrial planets we know more
about Mars than we do about any any
other planet we know more about Mars
because of the fact that we've sent so
many spacecraft to Mars the early the
early spacecraft just just flew by the
planet and snapped pictures on their way
past but then we sent spacecraft to
orbit and eventually land on Mars three
have actually landed on Mars two in 1976
and then Pathfinder more recently in the
late 1990s and we've got two spacecraft
in orbit around Mars right now taking
pictures as we speak and we've got two
spacecrafts that are on their way to
Mars to land in January that are
carrying two very cool very capable
Rovers let me just read you the the
overview that that we've written about
Mars Mars the fourth planet from the Sun
is smaller and lighter than Earth it's a
red rugged world with volcanoes poking
through the thin clouds and sheer cliffs
disappearing into canyons today the
planet is cold dry and desolate there's
no water on its surface no oxygen and
it's air and no life in its soil but
there's evidence that ancient Mars was
very different billions of years ago
Mars may have been a warmer planet
perhaps with ice-covered lakes a shallow
sea and possibly even primitive
microscopic life the Landers have given
us a detailed look at part
small parts of the surface of Mars this
is a picture taken from the Pathfinder
Lander looking at the Sojourner Rover
that probably most of you most of you
remember but Mars is a totally
fascinating place it's got the highest
mountain in the solar system Olympus
Mons it's got the longest deepest Canyon
in the solar system Valles Valles
Marineris it's a real interesting place
but it's most interesting because
there's a chance that primitive life
started on Mars at about the same time
that it started on earth early Mars did
have water we've got evidence of that
now and the NASA strategy for exploring
Mars is follow the water try to find out
where that water was where it is today
it's not on the surface but there's now
a lot of evidence that shows that
there's a huge amount of water not too
far below the surface either in ice form
or possibly in in liquid form so part of
the Mars strategy is to go to places
where we think there used to be water
and find out whether we can find
evidence of very early very primitive
life in any of those any of those spots
the giant planets are completely
different from the terrestrial planets
you couldn't land a spacecraft on one of
them if you wanted to they don't have
solid solid surfaces they're
qualitatively different they're much
larger they're made of much lighter
material primarily hydrogen and and
helium each one starts off with gas at
the top and the gas just gets thicker
and thicker and thicker and thicker
until it becomes so thick it becomes a
liquid and then you've got liquid going
down further and further and further
eventually you get to a core a core
about the size of Earth that's a solid
core inside these inside these planets
the planets themselves are really
interesting places all of them when they
started were so big once they formed
they were so big that they were big
enough to have little disks of matter
swirling around themselves so they were
within this disc in the solar system but
one was big enough that it had its own
discs so moons and rings formed around
each of these planets so each of the
giant planets has a lot of moons
unlike the terrestrial planets which
have either none or very few and they've
all got rings and that's something that
we've only discovered in the last couple
of decades
at first we thought Saturn was the only
one with rings but all four of these
have have rings Jupiter is the biggest
you could fit a thousand earths inside
of Jupiter its atmosphere is really
turbulent really stormy these colorful
bands that you see are in banded shape
because of really strong jet streams
that that go through the go through the
planet has very persistent storms cuter
has about 60 moons and we're still
discovering them all the time you know
we've discovered a bunch of them just
within the last year or so and those
moons range everywhere from small moons
that don't have names yet that are maybe
two miles across to the largest moon in
the solar system Ganymede which is
actually a moon that's larger than
mercury and its larger than than Pluto
one of the moons past that one of the
moons is possibly the most interesting
place in the solar system we're not sure
yet
but one of its larger moons called
Europa is a really interesting place the
whole surface of Europa is covered with
ice it's an ice-covered planet and that
ice is a few miles thick but below that
ice is a huge saltwater ocean you know
it's unbelievable but there is a big big
big saltwater ocean on a moon of Jupiter
and that leads scientists to speculate
that is very possible that primitive
life might have formed and might be
there in this ocean beneath the surface
of one of Jupiter's Jupiter's moons all
of the ingredients are there there's the
salt water our organic molecules and
there may be an energy source because
there are likely hydrothermal vents
on the floor of the Europa notions just
like there are hydrothermal vents on the
floor of our our ocean so it's a really
interesting question is going to be an
area of active exploration for NASA
they're going to be sending up a mission
to Europa in not too many years and this
is an artist concept of what would be
the grand and glorious Europa mission
probably many decades
out but here's a an artist concept of
something that has landed since a drill
down to drill through a couple miles
worth of ice breaking through to form to
to enter the ocean under Europa and
here's that the thing down at the bottom
it looks like it's about to swallow that
as a volcanic vent so that's what the
what this and of diving bill is hoping
to hoping to explore Saturn's the second
largest planet in the Solar System and
it's it's without a doubt the most
magnificent it's famous for its for its
rings and it's easy to see why Saturn is
very very much like like Jupiter it's
just a little bit of small a little bit
smaller it's got lots of moons 31 at at
last count there's a spacecraft on its
way to Saturn right now the Cassini
spacecraft is going to get there
in mid-2004 and go into orbit around
Saturn and that will be the first
spacecraft to spend a lot of time
orbiting Saturn and studying its moons
in a lot of a lot of detail one of the
very cool things that that spacecraft is
going to do is release a probe that will
study one of Saturn's Saturn's largest
moon and it's most interesting one by
far that moon is named Titan and Titan
is fascinating it's got a an atmosphere
about about the size of Earth's
atmosphere it's very unusual for a moon
to have much of an atmosphere at all and
Titans got a significant significant one
but Titan is interesting for reasons
beyond its atmosphere its atmosphere is
mostly nitrogen with a lot of methane
but the surface of Titan may
very well have a lot of liquid on it not
liquid water but liquid hydrocarbons
liquid ethane liquid methane so
scientists are now reasonably certain
that there are liquid rivers you know
hydrocarbon rivers and hydrocarbon lakes
on the surface of Titan and a probe is
going to be sent down through Titans
atmosphere to the surface this is an
artist concept of what that probe is
going to look like that probe will go
down to the surface in less than a year
from now so it's going to be a really
interesting thing to see what what that
probe finds now Uranus and Neptune are
also fascinating places but we're going
to skip right over them so that just in
the interest of time we can I can say
just a little bit about about Pluto and
then then take some some questions Pluto
as I said is different from all the
other planets the for terrestrial
planets are very similar to each other
they have significant differences but
you know if you were just kind of going
to categorize them as a family they'd be
very similar the giant planets same
thing they're similar to each other
Pluto's not like any of them it's it's
different
let me just read the overview of Pluto
that we've got in the book Pluto was
long considered a lonely outpost on the
edge of the solar system an odd little
planet different from all the others now
we know that Pluto is a relative of the
family of Kuiper belt objects that
formed in the cold outer reaches of the
solar system this tiny planet is smaller
than seven moons including our own it's
so far from the Sun that there's almost
no difference between night and day no
spacecraft has ever visited this dark
icy world and we know very little about
it you remember the icy planetesimals
that I described well Pluto is just the
largest of those tens of thousands of
icy relics from the the early days of
the solar system that is out orbiting
the Sun out beyond beyond Neptune so for
a long time scientists couldn't figure
out why Pluto was so odd and why you
know what it was doing out there now we
found out and this is just over the last
decade or so that we've discovered this
we've found out that it's
just one of a huge family of objects but
the largest of that that family of
objects we don't know much about it
because we've never sent a spacecraft
there it's the only planet that has had
no spacecraft visited we're planning a
mission to Pluto it's going to launch in
a few years and in a decade or so we'll
get our first close-up look at Pluto but
we don't know very much about it to give
you a sense of how difficult it is to
study Pluto if you don't send a
spacecraft to it this is a picture of
Pluto from the Hubble Space Telescope
not a lot of detail here but there are
some things that we have learned and one
of the interesting things is that Pluto
has a moon and it's kind of not just any
moon it's a huge moon given the size of
Pluto it's a moon that's almost half the
size of the planet and not only is it
much larger than average moons relative
to its planet it's also much much much
closer so our moon is a quarter of
million miles away our communication
satellites are about twenty-four
twenty-five thousand miles from Earth
Pluto's moon is about the distance that
our communication satellites are from us
so as a result Pluto is probably a
pretty dramatic place if you ever chose
to stand there for any length of time
this is an artist concept of what it
might look like on the surface of Pluto
pretty icy place you see the Sun on the
on the right so this is noon on Pluto
but up in the upper left you can see
kind of the crescent of its moon its
moon would look seven or eight times
larger in its sky band then our moon
looks in in our sky so it's a pretty
probably a pretty dramatic place and
we're going to know we're going to our
knowledge of Pluto is going to slowly
increase over the next decade and then
as soon as the spacecraft gets there
we're going to know an awful lot more
about it
so that takes us to the the end of the
solar system and that's a kind of a good
a good photograph to end on but the you
know I think the real message through
the book is that the spacecraft that
we've been able to send to the planets
in the solar system and the telescope's
that we've been able to train on these
planets just over the last few decades
have really changed the way we think
about the planets these planets are are
not dull places they're really
interesting places and there are
fascinating questions that relate to how
how earth began how life formed on earth
and how it fits in with kind of its
solar neighborhood that we're only going
to learn by by continuing to explore and
the next couple of decades of
exploration of the solar system are
really going to be interesting decades
it's a it's a great time to be alive if
you've got an interest in the solar
system thank you very much
so we've got some time for questions and
because we've got we're doing some we've
got c-span in here taping they've asked
me to ask you to ask your questions at
the microphones so I think we've got
microphones set up at both sides
go ahead two short questions why is
Pluto is its orbit so far out of the
ecliptic and why did the asteroid belt
not coalesce into a planet so why did
the astronaut it'd be the astronaut the
asteroid belt not coalesce into a planet
I didn't say much about the asteroid
belt but the asteroid belt is basically
made up of some of these old
planetesimals the rocks orbiting just
out beyond beyond Mars between Mars and
and Jupiter and why didn't those rocks
out there combine into a planet and it's
it's likely that Jupiter's gravity was
so much that just disrupted the planet
building process and didn't allow that
to happen
Pluto's orbit is different most of the
most of the planets in the solar system
orbit around the Sun in in a disc
they're all in the same plane and their
orbits or near circles they're pretty
close to circles Pluto is different it's
much more elongated it's much more
elliptical orbit than the other planets
and it's also inclined out of the solar
system it's like 17 degrees out of the
plane of the of the rest of them and I'm
not not the expert on this and I think
it's still part of the you know part of
what's interesting about Pluto but if
you think about this this large storm of
Kuiper belt Kuiper belt objects out
there many of them have orbits that are
not in the plane of the solar system
they're just a little bit a little bit
out of the plane and it essentially fits
in with this family of objects
yeah my background is in chemistry I'm
curious how somebody like me might get
more involved in NASA perhaps as a
science writer I have a master's in
chemistry I'm sure other people out
there probably wonder the same thing
like what opportunities are there there
are a huge number of opportunities for
chemists and for science writers within
within NASA and within within the space
program broadly and now beyond doubt
about them sorry how do you find out
about them actually the right place
probably one of the easiest ways is I
can talk I can talk to you afterwards
but also almost any NASA Center that you
wrote to or called up could could tell
you about the the way that chemistry is
involved in some of the work that they
do
so the NASA's Jet Propulsion lab has
chemists who are working on the early
chemistry of the planets and the
chemistry of early life and that that is
true of lots of the other NASA centers
they have different applications for for
chemistry but but it's one of the very
common areas of expertise how did dr.
Ryan how did dr. Wright on Derek Shannon
with the Mars Society and I was going to
ask you a science question about hot
Jupiters but since this band is here
it's got to be politics so what are your
thoughts on a lot of the Senate and
House hearings in the wake of Columbia
have been focusing on a renewed vision
for NASA and at the same time these
robotic spacecraft getting to Mars are
going to be arriving at a very key time
in the American political season what
are your thoughts on those for
catalyzing say new goals in space say a
return to human spaceflight beyond
low-earth orbit yeah you're exactly
right I think that this is this next
year is going to be very very important
an important time that gives the the
nation an opportunity to reassess its
vision of space exploration
and and come to come to a consensus on
where we want our space program to be
going and and how we want to describe
that and and categorize it
I think the Columbia tragedy really made
everyone at NASA and the rest of the
country step back and say you know okay
let's just let's let's think about what
we're doing let's think about whether we
need new space vehicles or not if we're
going to be thinking about that
obviously we want to we need to think
about what we want them to do and more
important we need to think about what we
want them to be part of what is the
overall the overall vision the Columbia
Board which I was a member of just
issued its report at the end of end of
August and NASA has begun responding to
that report and Congress as you noticed
as you noted has begun hearings on not
just the accident but the the larger
view of what NASA is going to be doing
and I think that this is up this is a
process that will go on for a period of
months and I think that the the Mars
landings are going to be an important
impetus to that that discussion I mean
those should be really very cool
landings and there's going to be a lot
of interest around those around those
Rovers so it's a it's an important
opportunity for us to to seize I think
to use this as a time to redefine our
our goals thanks so much and I'll get to
a copy of what we've been doing in the
Mars Society on our October briefing
book great let's stay with Mars you you
mentioned it would take about nine
months to to get there and I read an
article maybe a year ago about a manned
mission to Mars and a little bit
surprised to see that the mission
included spending about six months on
the surface
how likely is that to happen say within
the next 20 years and do you think use
you yourself from a psychological point
of view could spend that much time in
space you bet
you're on the list I were going to Mars
I could spend that time that's that's
actually right and it's a trip to Mars
you know think about it as having three
components one is getting there and our
technology could get us there in seven
or eight or nine months depending on
when we when we go and and how much fuel
we choose to expend getting there once
you're there though there are only
certain times when it's it's optimum or
even reasonable to launch for Mars from
Earth so the planets has to be in the
right relative positions that happens
about once every 26 months
that's why you tend to have spacecraft
going to Mars in clumps that's why we've
got two going going now and there's a
there also a couple of other spacecraft
from other countries that are that are
headed towards Mars that took advantage
of the same opportunity so every 26
months you have a chance to launch
something towards towards Mars once you
get to Mars now you've got the opposite
problem the planets have to be in the
right orientation for you to launch from
Mars back to earth and it turns out that
that requires a stay of three or four or
five or six months just depending on how
you set up the whole the whole trip so
you you do not have the option of just
because of orbital mechanics and and Sir
Isaac Newton you don't have the option
of landing on Mars and deciding the next
day to go home when you land on Mars
you're on Mars and you're on Mars for a
little while before you can you can come
home and then your return trip will be
six or seven or eight or nine months
just kind of depending on how you how
you structure the whole thing that's a
long time in a spacecraft that's a long
time in a spacecraft but you know
something if you were headed towards
Mars
you could you could fill the time
and in fact I should say that people
have been in space longer than that
eight month trip Russians have stayed
onboard the space station Mir for over a
year so we know that people can
physiologically handle that and we know
that they know that they can
psychologically handle it as well thank
you my question is very short and simple
your book at what age group are you
targeting with this book it's around
middle school it's good and this is your
fourth book yes and the others are the
same age group middle school high school
right around the same right around the
same age group a middle school high
school that's how I learned okay Don
Silverman with the obstacle Society of
America and my question first I'd like
to say reaching for the stars is very
inspiring and of course we've all seen
science fiction over the years where
people in science fiction travel to the
Stars and a hundred years ago or
whatever the timeframe was there are
people in science fiction going to the
moon or going to plant what kind of
paradigm shifts in fundamental physics
do you think might be necessary for
humans someday to reach the Stars based
on the concept that we just discussed
having a you know nine months and a year
just to get to Mars and what kind of
technologies might we be warp speed and
transporters I think it's what we what
we're going to need to start I mean just
to kind of set the scale the stars are a
long ways you know the nearest star is
you know a couple light-years away that
means it takes light a couple years to
get there nothing travels faster than
light and we don't travel even close to
the speed of light it's a you know light
hours to the end of the solar system so
it's really a difficult problem what do
you think it will take to solve the
problem
you know it'll take breakthroughs in
technology that we can't conceive of yet
or it'll take people with a lot of
patience
yeah hi this is a two-part question and
you don't have to answer it
oh great ok the first it has to do with
Columbia I know the damage the
spacecraft happened in the beginning
during launch or is that true human
verify that ok so let's say NASA
completely knew that this has happened
and potentially although I've heard
rumors that they did but let's say they
didn't or let's say that they did know
this and it was pretty evident that the
spacecraft would not make it back the
first part is a what is the protocol on
telling the astronauts this information
and the second part is being astronaut
yourself would you want to know so let
me let me answer an answer kind of a
third part of maybe what what could have
happened the the problem did happen on
launch and it is conceivable that and
everybody knew that the phone had hit
the space shuttle by the day after
launch that was well known people
however didn't assumed that it didn't
create any problem and didn't
investigate to find out whether it had
created a problem or not if they had and
if they had found that there was a hole
this big in the leading edge of the wing
which there was and there are actually a
couple of things that that could have
happened the Columbia Board actually
asked NASA to to look into could the
astronauts have repaired the the whole
the answer to that is they could have
tried there's a lot that they could have
done but it probably wouldn't make a
difference or could NASA have mounted a
rescue launched another space shuttle
and successfully transferred the crew to
the Space Shuttle that had just just
come up and you lose the Columbia but
you save the
astronauts and that the answer to that
was that although everything had to go
right that was conceivable Atlantis was
close enough to the launch pad that
without sacrificing any of the tests
just by going to 24-hour operation you
could have launched Atlantis well the
crew was still alive and gotten and the
once once Atlantis was in orbit the
actual transfer would have been a risky
spacewalk but not as risky as some
others that have been done so it was a
you know NASA understood how to how to
do that it would have something that
that could have could have happened okay
now like I said everything had to go
right you needed to discover that there
was this hole by about the fifth day of
the flight or so but you know that was a
conceivable thing so that puts your
question in a little bit different
perspective so the protocol for telling
the astronauts I mean if there were you
know they discovered that there was a
hole in the wing they would have told
the astronauts pretty much right then
that there was a hole in the wing and
we're going to try to figure out what to
do about it or what to have you to do do
about it and then the astronauts would
have been involved in all the
conversations and that's exactly what I
would have wanted because the you know
the astronauts are part just one part
but an important part of the team that
figures out what to do and then carries
out in some cases what would have to be
done so had they known that that that
the that that damage had been done on
launch they would have told the crew
almost right away and if there were no
options well you never know that there
are no options until you've explored the
options right so part of what NASA
normally does very very well is take a
problem like Apollo 13 and say you know
oh my gosh and how are we going to get
these guys back you know they're you
know they're on the way to the moon how
do we get them back and they didn't know
that you know at first I mean they they
had no
whether they could get the the Apollo 13
astronauts back and the same thing you
know until you really explore all the
options and all the alternatives you
know you just don't know so it's what
NASA does really well you know when they
kind of kick into that into that mode
thanks yeah okay hello after Columbia
there was a lot of talk about ending the
manned spaceflight program what do you
feel about that there still is there's a
lot of discussion not so much about
whether we should end human exploration
but under what conditions we should
carry it out and almost in what context
you know what's that what's what's the
the larger mission here and I think that
that's I mean I'm a real proponent of
human exploration and also of robotic
exploration I think there's a there's a
place you know there's a significant
place for both and we had had come to a
nice balance between between the two I
suspect that that balance is going to
continue but what what's really
important over the next many months is
to kind of engage not just NASA and the
Congress and in the White House but also
the American public in a debate of how
should we carry forward the program of
human exploration and I'm wondering what
research you're doing now are you going
back to space or well it turns out right
now I'm a professor of physics at
University of California San Diego but
I'm actually on leave from the
University and what I'm doing right now
is running a company that I founded
called imaginary lines that does things
like put on the science festivals put on
summer science camps for for girls we've
got a national Club for four girls and
we're running the toy challenge
competition that you may have may have
heard about earlier so that's how I'm
spending my time right now and it's all
focused on encouraging girls in fifth
through eighth grade or so to continue
their interest
science and math because it turns out
that in in right around fifth grade or
sixth grade depending on the girl that's
when you start to lose them and it's not
because they lose interest it's because
you know it may not be cool for a girl
to say that she's the best in the math
class or to say she wants to be an
electrical engineer and it's more for
societal reasons and kind of lingering
old stereotypes that girls can to drift
away in numbers much greater than boys
do right around that time great thank
you that actually fits very well into
what question I was going to ask
I'm with the Astronomy Department here
at UCLA and we do a lot of kind of
outreach things for the community but I
was wondering if you had other resources
that people can use to do outreach
towards younger younger audiences and
that sort of thing the Science Fair is
one of the one of the great ways to do
it but if there are other resources that
you know people can use and what to look
out for if you're interested in you know
space exploration that sort of thing
with yes maybe the best thing that I
could do is I can I can give you the the
website for the company but then I'd
also encourage you to talk to some of
the people here that are with imaginary
lines so the website for the company
that lists some resources and it
certainly lists our program and we're
happy to talk about other resources as
well is wwm a genera lines inc i NC comm
and you know we're happy to happy to
talk about it okay hi I know you said
you're on a leave of absence but if they
called you tomorrow would you go back up
to NASA yeah let me go back up on the
next shuttle yeah would I'd go back on
the next shuttle okay yeah one more
question
okay little boys little girls always
dreamed about being pilots and
astronauts and so much of aerospace now
is unmanned and I just wonder if there's
still that that possibility to be an
astronaut in the same capacity as it
used to be yeah there's probably more
opportunity for kids growing up today to
be astronauts
than than there was ten or fifteen or
twenty years ago and it's primarily
because the space program has been
expanding you know space shuttles you
know Germany capsules took two
astronauts up you know first there were
seven astronauts and then there were you
know then they added more they added
more the Apollo missions took three
astronauts to the moon well space
shuttles when they go up to take between
five and seven people and they go up to
the space station which has a permanent
staff up there so the opportunities are
expanding is the numbers are still
really low but I think that we're where
this is pointing in maybe maybe 10 or
maybe 15 maybe 20 years is for larger
numbers of people to be doing a greater
range of things in in space but I think
maybe more to the more to the point
rather than just asking you know how
many kids can grow up to be astronauts I
think you're exactly right that that
human exploration really kind of ignites
something in kids I mean they're really
excited by it and that's that's
something that you can take advantage of
you know if you can excite them about
something that that and then say okay
you're really you're really excited
about this then you better learn some
science you know this is what science is
it's this cool stuff it is there life on
Mars it's you know what's the physiology
of astronauts who are weightless I mean
if you don't know your science you can't
do these things and that's something
that that really kind of makes an
impression on kids and I think that
that's that's one of the values of of
our space program is that kids really
are interested in it and that gives us a
good opportunity for just keeping them
engaged thank you yeah thank you very
much
in 1983 Sally Ride became America's
first woman astronaut exploring our
solar system is published by Random
House children's books visit Random
House calm slash kids for more
information